the deep sea is vast dark and nearly
freezing cold
and it is also full of giants
as we begin to descend the ocean depths
we first pass through the epipelagic
zone here is where almost all ocean life
exists thanks to the sun's penetrating
energy
here animals are colorful and abundant
next we reach the mesopelagic zone also
known as the ocean twilight zone here
light becomes very dim and
photosynthesis becomes impossible
below a thousand meters all sunlight
disappears and we enter into the
midnight zone or the bathypelagic zone
the only light that can be seen down
here is the glowing bioluminescence from
the skin of squids or the lures of
anglerfish the pressure here is immense
the temperature's shockingly low but the
ocean goes deeper still
the abyssal pelagic zone reaches depths
of up to 6 000 meters with pressure 600
times that of our terrestrial world
the abyssal realm is considered the
single largest ecosystem for life on
earth covering 300 million square
kilometers about 60 percent of the
surface of the globe
but the deepness of the ocean doesn't
stop there
the hedo pelagic zone is the deepest
ocean region it's found from a depth of
about 6 000 to 11 000 meters and exists
in long narrow topographic v-shaped
trenches the deepest of these ever
discovered is the mariana trench
and despite all logic life survives in
these darkest depths
and the creatures here have evolved to
be exceedingly freaky
from the ghostly to the terrifying
to the absolutely gigantic
the giant japanese spider crab the big
red jellyfish the king of herring's
oarfish the giant squid the greenland
shark and the giant isopods these
animals are all examples of deep sea
gigantism the tendency that deep sea
animals have to be substantially larger
than their shallow water counterparts
in waters intensely cold and dark why do
these leviathans emerge is it an eerie
coincidence of the deep dark sea
or a feature of life in this
inhospitable landscape
[Music]
below 400 meters food becomes quite
scarce in the ocean as sunlight tapers
off photosynthetic algae and plankton
disappear too and without this crucial
part of the food chain life gets
markedly harder for deep sea animals
instead most of them have to rely on
detritus that rains down from shallower
waters a phenomenon called marine snow
marine snow is mainly composed of dead
plankton fecal pellets and bits of
rotting corpses that fall to the sea
floor as fine particles
some animals rely directly and
completely on marine snow
the vampire squid for example has
special adaptations to help them better
catch and eat the falling particles
two long filaments extend from their
bodies to capture any that drifts past
them in their habitat 900 meters deep
marine snow is the backbone for all life
in the deep but it can't support a great
deal of biomass the number of creatures
in the deep is sparse and the food web
is strained many animals don't eat
marine snow directly but rely on eating
those that do and thus the pressure of
predation is extremely high
any small fish crustacean or cephalopod
has a big target on its back from any
larger predator
and for this reason it became
evolutionarily advantageous for animals
to get rid of this target on their back
to transition from being a prey animal
into a top predator enter the giant
squid both an icon and an enigma of the
jeep by the turn of the 21st century the
giant squid remained one of the few
extant megafauna to have never been
photographed alive what we know about
the giant squid largely comes from
specimens that have washed ashore
it wasn't until 2004 that the first
photographs of a live giant squid in its
natural habitat were taken in the
twilight zone at a depth of about 1 000
meters
and while we may not know much about
these mysterious creatures we do know
that they are huge
the largest individual ever found was 13
meters long as long as a school bus and
weighing
275 kilograms compared to the majority
of squid which are no more than 60
centimeters long these giants are truly
exceptional scientists believe that by
having such a tremendous size they're
left with few predators and allows them
to comfortably prey on deep sea fish and
other squid species which they grab with
their two extremely long tentacles
but as impressive as the giant squid is
it is not the largest of the deep sea
squids
the colossal squid sometimes called the
antarctic squid is the largest
invertebrate in the world they're
shorter in length than the giant squid
at only 10 meters but can weigh between
500 and 700 kilograms lurking in depths
over 2 000 meters
it's easy to imagine such a massive
creature as an aggressive top predator
darting through the water snatching prey
and dominating its adversaries ripping
sailboats apart etc
but this squid teaches us something else
about deep sea giants they aren't
necessarily the dominating predatory
force we imagine because with their
large size comes something else an
extremely slow metabolism
the colossal squid takes something
called klieber's law to the next level
klieber's law states that metabolism
doesn't scale linearly with body size as
you might predict a horse that weighs a
thousand times more than a mouse doesn't
require a thousand times more energy
instead of metabolism scaling linearly
with body size it scales with an
animal's mass to the three-quarters
power this applies to all life on earth
from blue whales right down to
individual cells it's largely a
consequence of the physics and geometry
of animal circulatory systems an
animal's surface area to volume ratio
and the fractal nature of blood vessels
and all this means that the larger an
animal is the more efficient it is
and the colossal squid seems to be
exceedingly efficient one study
estimated the metabolic rate of the
colossal squid to be so low that they
only burn 45 calories per day and only
require
0.03 kilograms of food per day
a single adult tooth fish would be
enough food for a 500 kilogram colossal
squid for approximately 200 days their
energy requirements are 300 fold to 600
fold lower than other similarly sized
top predators of the southern ocean this
indicates that the colossal squid has a
particularly slow pace of life it
doesn't chase down its prey in epic
battles like we might imagine instead it
sits and waits for prey to unwittingly
approach then uses the hooks on its arms
and tentacles to ensnare it this
opportunistic lifestyle also makes sense
because in water so deep visual
predation would be nearly impossible due
to extremely limited visibility
the colossal squid does have the largest
eyes of any animal in the world up to 30
centimeters wide but scientists believe
these eyes are not for catching prey but
for detecting and avoiding predators
not many creatures could hunt a squid so
large but a select few can most notably
sperm whales
food scarcity and predator avoidance are
some of the major pressures for deep sea
animals to grow so large and have such
slow metabolisms but they are not the
only pressures
the deep cold water itself forces such
gigantism to occur
birdman's rule states that animals found
in cold environments will be larger than
those found in warm environments this
rule however has historically only been
found to be definitively true for
endotherms the warm-blooded animals like
birds and mammals does this trend also
apply to ectotherms the squids crabs and
isopods that inhabit the deep
it's a surprisingly controversial area
of science but it's clear that certain
species of ectotherm are indeed larger
at colder temperatures
this can certainly be seen in the polar
regions of the earth where marine
sponges worms and even single-celled
organisms get huge
and where the waters deep and polar
there's one of the strangest giants of
them all
the greenland shark is the largest fish
in the arctic ocean and one of the
largest sharks on earth seven meters
long and weighing as much as fourteen
hundred kilograms
it lives at depths over two thousand
meters where the water temperature is
between negative two and seven degrees
celsius it's the only shark that can
withstand the cold waters of the arctic
year round and this extremely cold
environment has caused the shark to not
just be huge but ancient
greenland sharks are the longest living
vertebrates in the world so old that
there are likely individuals swimming in
the sea that were alive before
christopher columbus voyaged to the
americas before michelangelo painted the
sistine chapel while the aztec and incan
empires were still thriving scientists
estimate their average lifespan to be at
least
272 years with some individuals living
perhaps well over 500 years
inside the shark's eyes there are
proteins that form before birth that are
then covered by many layers of the lens
of the eye these proteins do not degrade
with age so by carbon dating them
scientists can roughly determine the age
of the shark
one five meter female was assessed to be
between 272
and 512 years old these sharks don't
even reach reproductive age until around
150 years old
their astoundingly long life can be
attributed to their exceedingly low
metabolism much like the colossal squid
and just like the colossal squid they
are extremely slow and opportunistic
feeders they eat some fish and squid and
scavenge any carcass they can find their
stomach contents have even included
polar bears horses and reindeer just
like the giant squids they too would
struggle to spot and chase prey in the
pitch-black waters
but even if the water wasn't so dark the
sharks still couldn't see because a
particular crustacean constantly latches
on to their eyeballs damaging them to
the point of total blindness
the thought of drifting along in
negative two degree pitch black water
for 500 years with crustaceans attached
to your eyeballs gives me heebie-jeebies
of the highest order
the animals we've discussed so far are
certainly strange incredible and even
creepy but we've only gone as deep as
the miso and bathypelagic zones two
hundred to four thousand meters down the
ocean goes deeper still and reveals one
of the most extreme cases of deep sea
gigantism ever discovered
in the hadel trenches six thousand to
eleven thousand meters deep the
temperature varies between one and four
degrees celsius
there is no light and the pressure can
reach levels eleven hundred times that
of the surface here the marine snow that
gives life to most of the deep barely
trickles down ninety percent of it never
reaches past the twilight zone
at these depths it seems like life
should be impossible but instead the
deeper you go the more you'll find
colossal amphipods crawling along the
bottom
shallow water amphipods are usually
around 5 millimeters to 20 millimeters
in length but these deep water behemoths
can grow up to 34 centimeters long
something that's often the size of a
gnat at these depths is the size of a
guinea pig alicella gigantea is known as
the supergiant amphipod and is the
largest amphipod ever discovered their
gigantism is similar to that of the
giant isopods that can measure up to 50
centimeters long their roly-poly cousins
you might find in your garden are a mere
six millimeters long
these amphipods and isopods are
scavengers and detrivores eating any
decomposing material they can find and
their large body size may help them
store as much food and energy as
possible when they can find it relatably
when giant isopods find a significant
food source they gorge themselves to the
point of compromising their locomotive
ability by doing this they can survive
long periods of famine giant isopods
have been known to survive over five
years without food in captivity
their large body size also allows them
to travel greater distances in search of
their next meal
another reason for their huge body size
might have to do with the viscosity of
the water at such depths and cold
temperatures
down there water would feel thicker than
water at the surface larger body size
may give these deep sea invertebrates a
respiratory advantage that helps them
overcome the larger viscous forces in
the water
but even with all these factors it's
still hard to comprehend how there could
be enough food at these depths to
support these giants but recently
researchers discovered that some of
these creatures might be feeding on an
entirely unexpected food source
one hadal amphipod hierondalia gigas was
found to have a unique cellulase enzyme
one that seemed like its purpose was to
break down plant matter this was
surprising because absolutely zero plant
life can live in the hadel depths and
the amphipods wouldn't need this enzyme
to digest bits of algae in the form of
marine snow
yet when scientists tested the enzyme it
converted sawdust and wood pulp directly
into glucose and on top of this its
enzymatic activity increased under high
hydrostatic pressure the higher the
pressure the faster and more efficiently
the enzyme could digest cellulose
there may be no plants living in the
hadel zone but on occasion large pieces
of driftwood will sink all the way to
the bottom of the deepest parts of the
sea and being able to convert this wood
directly into energy is of high survival
value for an animal that doesn't have
many options
while we don't know much about the deep
sea we do know that it's a very delicate
ecosystem many of these animals already
live on a knife edge of survival and any
change to their environment could mean
the end for these giants
overfishing plastic pollution changes in
ocean chemistry due to climate change
and deep sea mining are all threats to
this incredible ecosystem
these creatures may seem like they live
in a far off alien planet but it's still
very much connected to and dependent on
ours and scientists now believe we very
well may be dependent on their world too
we are only beginning to understand the
intrinsic connection between ocean
ecosystems and the links between them
and the terrestrial environments in
which we live
and most importantly who wants to live
in a world that's been stripped of its
wonder of its dazzling mesmerizing and
baffling deep sea creatures we as a
species are so focused on trying to find
alien life on other planets that we
often forget about the unthinkable
creatures that are living right under
our noses or rather under many miles of
ocean
if you're like me the news in the world
lately makes you desperately wish you
too lived at the bottom of the ocean
maybe the greenland shark floating alone
in the darkness with parasites on its
eyeballs is actually onto something i
bet the greenland shark doesn't
doomscroll itself into insomnia every
night or begin the day with a cup of
anxiety reading the front page of reddit
and all its associated threads of
arguing and stupidity
but since i am unfortunately a human i
often do exactly these things
i want to stay informed but then find
myself getting sucked into the news in
social media working myself up trashing
my mental health and honestly wasting a
lot of time
so this is why i've switched my morning
news routine to morning brew
morning brew can't make the news better
but it can make it understandable and
digestible
morning brew gets you up to speed on
business finance and tech in just 5
minutes and their recaps are
refreshingly witty there's no comment
section to accidentally fall into so you
can read about elon musk and twitter's
feud with just the information and not
the fanboy commentary
or you can quickly understand what's
going on with the stock market without
the speculation
and the best part of all of this is it's
completely free plus by signing up you
are greatly supporting this channel
if you've ever thought about signing up
to any of our sponsors now is the
perfect time all it takes is 15 seconds
and an email address
so to get a new and improved morning
news routine click the link in the
description to get started with morning
brew today
and if you'd like to watch something
else right now you should watch our
previous video about the world's
deadliest snake or watch real
engineering's latest video about the
engineering of self-healing spacesuits
[Music]
you